YUFENG GUO: Hi, I'm
here with Chris Law
to learn more about how to
protect highly sensitive data
from being exfiltrated.
CHRIS LAW: Hi, Yufeng.
Happy to be here.
YUFENG GUO: So I've
seen a lot of headlines
over the last year
about big data breaches.
And they seem to be
getting bigger and bigger.
What's going on?
CHRIS LAW: Yes, any company
storing sensitive data
needs to be ready to protect
against data breaches.
YUFENG GUO: And so when you
say highly sensitive data, what
do you mean exactly?
CHRIS LAW: Highly
sensitive data can
be things like social
security numbers, credit card
numbers, or patient data.
This includes things
like PII, that's
personally identifiable
information,
financial information, or PHI.
And that's protected
health information.
But highly sensitive
data could really
be any data that your company
deems to be sensitive.
But the good news
is Google Cloud
can help protect this data.
I'll show you how.
So let's say you're
building your finance app,
and your partner is sending
you a bunch of data.
The partner is sending you both
sensitive data in red here,
and non-sensitive data in green.
YUFENG GUO: Got it.
So I really want to keep
that red golf ball secure.
CHRIS LAW: Exactly.
Now the easiest way to get
this data from the partner
is to create a public
bucket in Google Cloud
and give them access to it.
So now, as you can
see, the partner
is sending the sensitive
data and non-sensitive data
all into this one bucket.
But there's a problem
with that setup.
And it's that
unauthorized parties
can get access to
these public buckets
and can exfiltrate the data.
And any exposure of, say, social
security numbers or credit card
information can put you and
your company in the headlines.
But the good news is
developers like yourself
can use Google Cloud's
Identity and Access Management
System, or IAM, to restrict
access to the bucket that
stores this sensitive data.
YUFENG GUO: So
how does IAM work?
CHRIS LAW: With
IAM, as a developer,
you can control exactly
which users have access
to the new restricted bucket.
And each user will have to
securely authenticate in order
to get any access to data.
YUFENG GUO: Right.
So as a developer, I can
just lock this bucket down
so only a few people
can access it?
CHRIS LAW: Exactly.
Anyone trying to get access to
data in your restricted bucket
needs to be authorized
before they can get access
to any sensitive data.
YUFENG GUO: So I have
this new restricted bucket
with limited access.
How do I get the social security
number data into that bucket?
CHRIS LAW: Great question.
Well, let's take a look
at how you can do it.
One way you can sort this
social security number
data into this restricted
bucket is to do it manually.
The problem with this approach
is that it might make a mistake
and categorize the data wrong.
So in this example,
I might accidentally
miscategorize the social
security number data
and put it into
the public bucket,
exposing it to the wrong people.
YUFENG GUO: Got it.
CHRIS LAW: For highly
sensitive data like this,
it makes sense to automate this
sensitive data classification
process as much as possible.
And that's what developers
use Google Cloud's Data Loss
Prevention, or DLP API, for.
DLP can identify over
90 plus different types
of common sensitive data types
like social security numbers
and credit card numbers.
So with DLP enabled, now when
the partner sends you data,
DLP will automatically identify
the social security numbers
and automatically put that data
into the restricted bucket.
YUFENG GUO: Amazing.
CHRIS LAW: Pretty cool.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah.
CHRIS LAW: So now that we've
automated this process,
we've got the sensitive
data all going
into the restricted bucket,
and only a few select users
have access to it.
YUFENG GUO: Great.
So can I launch my app now?
CHRIS LAW: Not just yet.
This setup works fine as long
as the partner sends the data
into the right API.
But let's say they
accidentally email
through a bunch of sensitive
social security number data.
So over here, we have a bunch
of e-mails, white golf balls,
and e-mails with sensitive
data, which are red golf balls.
Anyone who receives
this email can
download the social security
number data into to machine
or forward it into
a personal drive.
This makes it much more
likely to be exposed.
YUFENG GUO: So how can we keep
this social security number
data out of inboxes?
CHRIS LAW: To
handle this problem,
you can use Google Cloud's
Data Loss Prevention
technology in G Suite.
So with G Suite DLP set up,
the social security number data
within the e-mails gets
automatically detected
and moved into a
quarantine bucket.
YUFENG GUO: And so now
that social security data
doesn't hit my inbox.
CHRIS LAW: Exactly.
And once the data is moved
into the quarantine bucket,
admins can review and
handle it more securely.
YUFENG GUO: So we've got
the social security number
data going securely into
this restricted bucket.
And now only a few select
users can access it.
But what's to stop one
of these legitimate users
from just stealing the data?
CHRIS LAW: Right,
great questions.
Insider attacks
are also a threat.
So even if you're putting the
data in a secure environment,
a user who is granted
access to that data
may have malicious
intent and might
try to exfiltrate the data.
Leaks like this can be
contained and controlled
using Google Cloud's
VPC Service Controls.
With VPC Service Controls, we
can set up a secure access zone
that acts as a perimeter
around the sensitive data
so even insiders can't
move the data out.
YUFENG GUO: So even a user
I granted legitimate access
to would not be able to
exfiltrate that data.
CHRIS LAW: That's right.
YUFENG GUO: What if an admin
goes in and just changes
these settings?
CHRIS LAW: With Google Cloud's
Forseti open source security
tools, you can set up an alert.
So when an admin makes any
changes to sensitive data
settings, an alert can be
sent to Cloud Security Command
Center so that even admin
access can be monitored.
YUFENG GUO: Wow.
So are we ready to
launch the app now?
CHRIS LAW: Well, let's take
a look at your finance app.
The partner is sending you
social security number data
and it's all being categorized
in the right bucket.
There's a secure access
zone around the data.
And even if the partner
sends social security number
data via email, that data is
automatically quarantined.
I think you're ready
to launch your app.
YUFENG GUO: Great.
Well, Chris, thanks
for showing me
how developers and companies can
protect highly sensitive data
like this with Google Cloud.
CHRIS LAW: My pleasure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]